Salut la Team Mentalo !
Et bon dimanche, pour ceux qui regarde la vidéo le jour de sa sortie
Pour la 1ère fois,
sur la chaîne du Mental Vlog
je vais vous parler d'un livre
de Mentalisme
Alors je demande,
un générique
*Générique*
Salut la Team Mentalo,
avant de commencer
les résultats du concours pour le livre de Bernard Werber sont
dans la description
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un livre de Mentalisme
qui est ..
surement le plus important pour moi
En tout cas, dans mon parcours à moi
c'est un livre que j'ai extrêmement apprécié
Il s'agit
de Ex Nihilo
d'Angelo Stagnaro
On le voit bien à la caméra
Très bonne idée
que je viens d'avoir,
vous faire voir l'ISBN aussi
si jamais vous avez du mal à le trouver
ce qui va être forcément le cas
vous aurez l'ISBN c'est plus facile pour faire la recherche
je vous la mets dans la description également.
Bon, tout confondu, c'est un des livres
qui a été le plus important dans ma vie en tant que mentaliste
mais c'est peut être aussi parce que c'est au moment où j'ai rencontré ce livre
que c'était plutôt pas mal
Avec une petite image qui fait peur au début wouaaahhh
Alors je vais vous lire le petit descriver qu'il y a au tout départ
Une analyse du langage du corps,
de l'intuition, de l'équivoque, de l'interprétation des mouvements musculaire
du charisme, de anthropologie culturelle, des statistiques,
des forces *Inspiration*
psychologiques
et des tours mentalistes automatiques,
de l'observation, de la causalité et du bon sens.
"Réjouissez-vous en secret de tout ce que vous savez. C'est le plus difficile."
Il y a marqué ici que c'est la deuxième partie de la trilogie "ouvrages psychologiques"
j'ai jamais trouvé le 1er ou le 3ème
Je ne sais même pas comment ils s'appellent
Pour lire ce bouquin il faut quand même être ouvert d'esprit
et il y a des choses qui sont un peu bullshit aujourd'hui là dedans.
Mais ça permet d'avoir un aperçu très large.
Et on se dit que c'est un tout petit livre
et que c'est quand même bizarre
que je dise que ce soit extrêmement large
ça l'est !
Je vous fait voir la taille comme ça du sommaire
et il y a l'autre page aussi de l'autre côté
On va retrouver, dedans, des choses pour déchiffrer l'autre
les observations médicales
les résumés générales des comportements
l'interprétation des mouvements musculaires
des choses sur l'équivoque
des choses sur des forces psychologiques
des repères mnémotechniques
Choses très intéressantes que j'ai pas vu dans beaucoup de bouquins
il y a la philosophie du mentalisme,
les problèmes d'éthiques, les mises en garde
On y parle de choses très larges comme l'effet Barnum,
que vous êtes nombreux, je crois à connaitre.
Et il y a cette définition que j'aime beaucoup aussi à un moment donné
qui est :
Un illusionniste essaie de duper l’œil,
un ventriloque essaie de duper l'oreille
et un mentaliste essaie de duper l'esprit.
C'est intéressant ça
Et on y retrouve une bibliographie extrêmement riche pour ceux qui parlent anglais
alors là c'est magique pour vous
Mais vous allez aussi trouver des références à des livres en français
même si je vous le dis c'est quand même assez rare.
Au niveau du contenu, on est vraiment sur le déchiffrage de l'autre
La lecture de l'autre
et aussi sur des choses d'influences
C'est vraiment un livre conseil,
c'est à dire que c'est pas extrêmement fun à lire
par contre, l'auteur vous parle à vous directement
et vous donne des conseils
à vous d'avoir l'esprit critique aussi,
le sens critique pour savoir ce qui
est bon pour vous comme conseil ou pas.
Il y parle de ces recherches,
il y parle de sa propre expérience
il y parle de ces propres conclusions
Mais soyons clair,
c'est pas un livre... pour se marrer
mais pour autant il est pas difficile à lire
il est vraiment accessible à tout le monde
Après c'est comme tous les livres
Lire c'est bien
Après s'entraîner et appliquer et retenir c'est autre chose
et c'est une vraie volonté de travail qu'il faut derrière.
Le livre en lui même
il ne fera rien à part vous amener un petit peu de connaissance...
élargie
Par contre, si vous vous mettez à apprendre ce qu'il y a dedans
à essayer de le retenir
et encore mieux
à l'appliquer
Alors c'est un vrai bon premier pas
vers le mentalisme
Mais le petit reproche à faire vers le mentalisme ciblé
En même temps,
Non ! Je fais un reproche
Non c'est dégueulasse. Je vais pas faire de reproche
parce qu'il y a quand même écrit ici en gros:
Guide du cold reading
Il n'y a pas marqué...
on va voir tout ce qui fait parti du mentalisme
donc c'est vraiment même plus ciblé
sur la lecture et l'interprétation des personnes.
Mais ça ouvre un petit peu vers autre chose
et ça reste quand même un bon point de départ
Je vais essayer de trouver des liens internet pour vous le procurer
je vous le mettrais dans la description
Si il n'y en a pas ça sera simplement que j'en ai pas trouvé
et dans ces cas là je vous conseille d'aller dans vos librairies habituelles
avec le numéro d'ISBN que je vous mets
et d'aller leur demander si ils peuvent en commander
Puisque vous êtes là et qu'on est dimanche
et que je suis tranquillement assis, avant même que le soleil ne se soit levé
je vais vous donner quelques petites infos supplémentaires
L'info, par exemple, de la vidéo de demain
elle va parler de la théorie du Yes,
vous savez comme dans le film Yes man
je connais quelqu'un qui a fait ça durant 30 jours
et on va en parler ensemble sur la chaîne, c'est vraiment intéressant
d'avoir le retour de quelqu'un qui la fait.
Toujours dans les vidéos, je sais que j'ai pas encore fait la vidéo du Mind Map
mais elle me prend beaucoup de temps à faire
et je ne veux pas gâcher parce que vous m'avez envoyé des super choses
donc je suis en retard mais elle va sortir
probablement cette semaine
Je vais être en spectacle en Suisse le 21 et 22 octobre à Lausanne
Vous avez le lien vers mon site dans la description
Il y a toutes les dates de tournée dessus,
mais vraiment toute la tournée jusqu'à mars/avril
Si je ne suis pas dans votre ville. On va rajouter des dates rassurez vous
Mais n'hésitez pas à réserver
Par exemple, pour Lille
pour Mulhouse et pour Lyon
ça part assez vite
Et je vous rappelle qu'à chaque fin de spectacle, on se rencontre
on prend le temps ensemble
Je prend vraiment du temps, il y a pas de soucis
et c'est parce que ça me fait vraiment plaisir à moi aussi à chaque fois.
Et enfin pour ceux qui sont vraiment rester aussi loin de la vidéo
la petite info exclu pour vous
Tout en vous parlant de livre
Je vais vous le dire
Ça fait quelque temps j'ai décidé d'écrire un livre
qui sortira je sais pas quand, je sais pas comment
J'en avais parlé une fois dans la FAQ
Je sais pas...
comment ça va se passer
mais on va bien trouver un chemin pour ça.
Et l'important c'est de l'écrire
Et il y a le Nanowrimo tous les ans
Si vous connaissez pas c'est un délire mondial de personnes qui écrivent.
Je vais le faire. C'est tous les ans au mois de novembre
comme je n'ai pas assez de choses à faire dans une journée
je vais me rajouter ça.
Je vais le faire au mois de novembre,
je vous ferai une vidéo à ce sujet là
mais je me lance
au moins dans le fait d'essayer d'écrire quelque chose
Sortir de sa zone de confort.
C'est ça qui est cool
Bon je suis en train de faire une 2ème vidéo dans la vidéo
Merci d'avoir regarder jusqu'au bout.
Je vous souhaite un bon dimanche
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
Mettez un pouce en l'air
Parce que ça fait plaisir
et puis ça aide à référencer la vidéo dans le système de YouTube
et c'est ce genre de choses qui fait que la chaîne et de plus en plus visible
N'oubliez pas d'ailleurs de vous abonner avant de partir.
ça, c'est important
Et le Mental Vlog c'est quoi c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
On doit être à la 283ème vidéo
Je crois
Peut être 282
En tout cas rendez vous demain à 17h
Ciao !